-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Henry Winkler.
We've talked in the past.
I think anyone who follows you
on social media
knows you are an avid fisherman.
-I am.
-And Stacey, your wife --
-Is better than I am.
-Is she better than you?
-The last time we went,
this past September,
her fish were bigger.
-Wow.
-Yeah.
And I don't know --
We were using the same fly.
I don't know how it happened.
-Gotcha.
Were you celebratory
of her success?
-Well, outside I was.
-Yeah? Oh, that's good.
That's all anyone
can ask from a spouse.
You don't have to
believe a thing.
You just have to
show it in public.
-Just, "Oh, my!
That is phenomenal!"
-"I'm going to go
stand by this tree
and face away from you now."
-That's why we fish
in different boats.
-Oh, that's very smart.
-Yeah.
-So I don't have to experience
her pulling out
these beautiful trout
and mine are just "tr."
-You went to Yale Drama School.
-I did.
-Can I show my favorite photo
from the book?
-Sure.
-Because it just --
I can't even believe
this was you.
Check out young Henry there.
Like, who --
[ Audience "oohs" ]
Yeah, that is absolutely
the appropriate response.
-I thought that was going to be
my first headshot.
-That is --
What roles did you want?
[ Laughter ]
You were like, "I'm a biker
and also a fisherman."
-Yes, and I wanted --
I wanted to play an Irishman.
-Yeah. You did.
I mean, it's so funny.
I mean, I guess
if you were the Fonz,
you could have been
an Irishman, too.
I mean, you might as well,
right?
-Really.
-You could have done them all.
I also want to ask --
So you grew up
and you wrote a series of books,
"Hank Zipzer."
-Yes.
-And these are children's books
about the fact
that you had dyslexia
when you were young.
And these are books
for young readers.
-Right, and I understood now
what it was like to be 8
and to fail
and to understand now
that no matter how difficult
it is to learn,
no matter how difficult it is
for you to be in school,
it has nothing to do with who
you are or how smart you are.
-That's a lovely message
for kids.
How many of the Zipzer books
have you written now?
-There are 28 Hank Zip--
Now, the the newest one
is "Detective Duck,"
and she just came out
14 days ago.
-Wow, look at this.
Two books in 14 days.
-It's unbelievable.
-Unbelievable.
-With Lin Oliver.
And she is a little duckling.
She lives on a pond,
the picture of which I found
when we were doing a jigsaw
puzzle over the pandemic.
-Yeah.
-And there was a picture
of a pond in New Hampshire,
and we said,
"That's where the duck lives."
-Wow! So the thing
that was stopping you
from writing this book
was you didn't know
what the pond looked like?
[ Laughter ]
-I was torn.
-Yeah.
You probably had a bunch
of ponds to choose --
-There was a pond
in Winston-Salem.
-Sure.
-But not as good-looking.
-Yeah. I mean, I bet
there were a lot of people
who were sending you
pictures of their ponds.
-And you know what?
And I have to say,
they weren't great.
-Yeah.
-I got a lot
of bad pictures of ponds.
-When you go over
to your house now,
you got photo albums
full of your bad ponds.
-Really.
-Yeah.
-I've put them in a shed.
-Yeah, well,
as a kid with dyslexia,
do you ever look back and go,
"Oh, my God, look at all
these books that I've written"?
-When I see my name on a book,
I am telling you I am --
I was 78 two days ago, and --
[ Cheers and applause ]
And everything about me is young
except for my knees
when I stand up.
But anyway, when I see my name
on a book, it is --
I'm overwhelmed.
When I saw my name
the first time,
I'm at a meeting
and I'm talking to the buyers
all across the country of books.
And I look down, and there is
my name on a book
as a part of a writing team.
My brain turned to cream cheese.
Literally, I stopped talking.
I picked up the book
off the table.
I rubbed it all over my body.
[ Laughter ]
I smelled it.
I am not joking.
-Did your editor say,
"Stop doing that"?
-Yes.
-"Stop doing it.
You're scaring the buyers."
-They escorted me out before
the appetizer, and I was hungry.
-Yeah, well, can I tell you
where I'm happiest
to see your name
is when I get an e-mail
from our talent department
saying Henry Winkler
is coming back on the show.
-Thank you.
-It makes me so happy.
What a joy it is
every single time you're here.
You guys, that is Henry Winkler,
everybody.
"Being Henry: The Fonz...
and Beyond" is available now.
We'll be right back
with Brendan Hunt.